heute früh schon wieder Angriff von
Hauptstadt durch eine Kiew habe schon 40
mal gesagt ich möchte hier noch einmal
wiederholen es ist gar nichts Besonderes
Kief war und bleibt ein Ziel von Adresse
und heute habe ich seine riesige Angriff
für mehr 70 Raketen in
Richtung geflogen mehr als 40 Raketen
ähm ist abgeschossen aber teilweise
Raketen doch hat unsere Stadt getroffen
deswegen ist 51 Menschen sind verletzt
42 bleibt bis jetzt den Krankenhäuser
paar Leute in kritische Zustand
5 Leute sind gestorben und die Zeit von
gestorbenen kann noch steigen weil er
paar Leute ist noch im kritischer
Zustand in unserer Krankenkasse ich habe
gesagt
aber ein so schlimmen Angriff auf Kiel
haben wir ja bisher nicht erlebt mitten
ins Zentrum der Stadt das hat doch eine
neue Qualität oder
das ist keine neue Qualität ist nichts
Neues weil er vor paar Wochen vor paar
Monate das ist wir haben wir haben schon
Angriffe gehabt und möchte ich noch
einmal sagen mehr als 600 Gebäude in
unserer Stadt seit Anfang September
zerstört
Apartments die Wohnhäuser zerstört und
seit dieser Zeit ist
26 Leute sind gestorben und vier Kinder
und noch zusätzliche heute hier
schlimmere Teil von verletzte und geht
oder Menschen
sie haben ja den Bürgern der Stadt Kiew
empfohlen dass Sie Ruhe bewahren sollen
in die Bunker gehen sollen glauben Sie
dass die Situation jetzt noch weiter
gefährlich ist sie sind weiter
gefährlich dass wir leben in
der Krieg und deswegen
ständig hören wir eine
Luftangriff Alarm und deswegen jeder
jede Anwohner weist genau Bescheid
Regeln die mussten sofort wann die Türen
die Alarm die mussten den Bunker eine
sichere Platz
sie befinden bis zum Zeit wenn er Raumes
aus
jetzt hat Präsident selensky gefordert
dass es ein g7-treffen jetzt sofort
geben muss wie schätzen Sie das ein was
kann die westliche Welt jetzt überhaupt
tun in dieser Lage
habe schon sich mal gesagt dass es
sicher keine
Nummer eins für jede Burger von unserer
Stadt von unserer Land und deswegen wir
brauchen auch moderne Abwehrsysteme das
ist gegen Raketen eher besonders in
unserer Stadt so das macht die Leben von
unsere Anwohner ist viel sicherer
deswegen wir brauchen Hilfe zu schützen
Leben von unserer Anwohner
jetzt haben ja viele Menschen die aus
dem Osten kommen gerade in leviv und
Kiew auch Schutz gesucht was bedeutet
das für die die haben ja damit gerechnet
dass wahrscheinlich die Lage hier etwas
sicherer ist als im Osten der Ukraine
ja die
bessere Sicherheit als andere Städte
aber trotzdem Vision heute das ist
große Teil von Raketen jetzt
abgeschlossen aber trotzdem ist
keine befindet sich noch eine hat
Sicherheitsgarantie deswegen
wir wollen in
solche kritische Zustand in den Krieg
und deswegen Sicherheit zu garantieren
können wir haben keine
wir erleben Sie die Bevölkerung sind die
Menschen in Angst und Panik hat Russland
das erreicht was wohl auch mit diesen
Angriffen bezweckt wird und die Ziel von
Putin von russische Regierung dass es
eine Panik zu peinlich zu verbreiten das
ist Leute muss die malisiert sein statt
dem habe ich schon mit vielen Menschen
gesprochen
Leute haben nur eine riesige Wut
weil und bereit unsere Land und unsere
Städte zu verteidigen weil das ist
unsere zu Hause das ist unsere Familie
unsere Kinder
deswegen
der Russen erreichen sein Ziel nicht
sogar Gegenteil wurde sind wütig und
wir haben keine Angst wir werden wir
haben keine andere Wahl wir werden
unsere Land beteiligen
wie haben sie sich heute morgen gefühlt
ich bin verantwortlich für kritische
Infrastrukturen in unserer Stadt das ist
neue Herausforderungen und sehr viel
ständig dass es ich mache Sorgen ich
mache sorgen sofort habe ich mit nur
unsere Militär
Leute gesprochen habe ich
gefordert die Luft
Abwehrsystem noch mehr zu haben und
leben von unserer Anwohner zu sichern
ja ist das noch mal jetzt eine ganz
besondere Herausforderung noch mal die
Frage weil wir erleben ja jetzt schon
eine deutliche Eskalation in Kiel
denn sie ist noch besondere Maßnahmen
ergreifen
das ist eine Lügerei das ist die Russen
verbreiten eine Lügerei ständig das ist
eine spezielle Operation gegen
rechtsradikalen gegen Narzissten gegen
Faschisten dass es eine Lügerei das ist
eine Lügerei das ist eine Kampf gegen
eine Militär weil wir sehen dass es die
Ziel unsere Anwohner diese Zivilisten
und Schuldige Menschen und unschuldige
Menschen sterben und
Putin braucht doch eine ohne Ukraine
klare Antwort jetzt sehe ich in den
sozialen Medien dass manche Menschen
auch fordern die Ukraine muss jetzt auch
mal stärker gegen Russland Vorgehen
fürchten sie auch da dass die Regierung
und sie unter Druck geraten
wir haben keine andere Wahl gibt das ist
keine das ist gibt keine Option das ist
irgendwo nach Westen
auswandern dass es unsere Heimat unsere
zuhause wir wollen hier leben mit
europäischen Werten wir wollen nicht
zurück zum isolierte Union wir sehen
unsere Zukunft als Teil in europäische
Familie und wir kämpfen für
demokratische werten wir kämpfen für
menschliche Rechte
in unserem Land das passt nicht in
Vision von Putin weil er will wieder
russische Imperia mi wieder aufzubauen
wir wollen
zusammen wollen wir wollen wir nicht
zurück in Vergangenheit deswegen werden
wir kämpfen wir haben keine andere Wahl
wir kämpfen für unsere Kinder für unsere
Zukunft für unsere Land wie sehen sie
persönlich die Situation in Russland da
hat sich ja jetzt in letzter Zeit auch
eine Menge entwickelt mit den Protesten
gegen die Mobilisierung mit den
Hardlinern die dort deutlich mehr
Gewicht bekommen haben wie schätzen Sie
das ein ich bin mehr als sicher
kommt ganz bald die richtige Frage und
schon die Frage der russische
Bevölkerung stellen das ist eine große
Tragödie für durch eine für Millionen
von Menschen und eine große tragetier
für auch für russische Bevölkerung und
russische Bevölkerung wird die Frage
stellen an seine Regierung wieso die
können nicht so einfach
Reisen in andere Länder wieso ist eigene
Vorrang kommt wieder wieso ist
Weltunternehmen verlassen Russland und
die wichtigste Frage die werden stellen
wie sollen welche Grund mein Bruder mein
Sohn mein Sohn um einen bekannte meine
Verwandten gestorben wo ist die Grund
und müssen wir nicht vergessen das ist
schon 1.000 und 1000 russische Soldaten
sind gestorbene suche eine und
jetzt neue Mobilisierung und
vorbereitete Leute Putin schickt nach UK
und das bedeutet die Proteste
Welle kommt ich bin mehr als sicher
kämpfen aber wie geht es weiter
wir haben keine andere Wahl wir das ist
unsere Heimat wir wollen nicht
auswandern das ist wir wollen hier
erleben aber mit
Regeln eine moderne europäische Land
europäische Stadt und deswegen bleibt
nicht viel übrig wir müssen kämpfen und
verteidigen unsere Häuser unsere Städte
unseres Land aber wie lange wird dieser
Krieg noch gehen stellen Sie sich auf
eine längere Zeit ein was was ist da
ihre Perspektive wissen Sie was ich
leider keine einzige Experten der Welt
kann nicht antworten diese Frage geben
wie lange diese Krieg sinnlose Krieg wir
dauern
wir hoffen dass es unsere Zukunft unsere
Ziele unsere Traum das ist schnell wie
möglich die Krieg muss beenden aber die
er muss beenden nur mit einer Aufgabe
die wenn russische der letzte russische
Soldat verlasst unsere Territorium
unseres Land
sie haben ja sehr gute Beziehungen auch
nach Deutschland was erwarten sie jetzt
von Deutschland kann Deutschland jetzt
in dieser Situation noch einmal etwas
bewirken etwas tun ich möchte eine sehr
wichtig die sehr wichtige
message habe ich für Deutschland wir
kämpfen heute in buchraine und wir
kämpfen für hier den durch Europa weil
wir haben genau das gleiche Werte putin
will ist sowjetische Imperia wieder
aufzubauen und ihr deutsche muss nicht
vergessen ein großer Teil von
Deutschland auch war ein Teil von
sowjetische Imperia und hören wir
stimmen in Kreml die wollen schon
baltische Länder die wollen und die
gehen soweit wie weit wir Leben zu gehen
und deswegen wir kommen wir kämpfen
heute nicht für durch eine und
verteidigen nicht unsere Familie wie
Verteidigung euch und wir erwarten auch
Unterstützung in diese Krieg wir
brauchen eine Verteidigungswaffen ich
möchte betonen betonen Verteidigungs wir
sind Ukraine eine öffentliche Volk
friedliches Land wir waren niemals
aggressiv gegen keine keine von unseren
Nachbarn und was passiert heute das ist
eine riesige Verbrechen gegen die
Menschen und deswegen wir erwarten eine
große und mehr Unterstützung von
Deutschland von europäischen Länder von
die ganze Welt weil er wieviel seidigen
genau das gleiche Werte wie sehen Sie
die Debatten in Deutschland um die Frage
der Energiepreise die Angst der Menschen
davor dass Deutschland in eine
wirtschaftliche Krise stürzen kann
alle alles Geiser
die sagt wir haben uns hier einen Teil
von der Ukraine und die jeder Angriff
dass es Angriff fahren unsere
Territorien jetzt und gibt nicht Umfrage
das ist unsere Interesse und
danach die bieten
billige Energie wenn nein dann bekommen
wir nicht das ist wie eine piratenstiel
das ist Fabriken Stil das ist so geht
nicht und moderne Welt
aber heute das ist eine riesige
Herausforderung für die ganze Welt was
Russland macht
aber wir kämpfen Unabhängigkeit was
bedeutet auch unabhängig von Energie
Ressourcen weil das war langjährige Ziel
abhängig alle von russischen die Energie
zu machen und die hat teilweise das
geschafft
nächste Winter was kommt
ist eine
riesige Herausforderung riesige Prüfung
wird für uns für die Ukraine und auch
für ganz Europa und
wir müssen kämpfen das ist und
wenn schaffen wir dann werden wir viel
stärker
[Musik]